let's go to our next caller from the
three one eight area code caller from
three one eight go ahead want to ask
your opinion you probably already have
say something about this but I think are
you sure about are you sure about this
blue waves knowing it's coming because I
believe on the left we kind of have a
little bit of hubris about because we
just figured that people are gonna
figure it out a week or we're usually
right on certain things oh no no no no
no yeah I don't know if you've missed
some of my recent shows John and by the
way if we're on speakerphone or a
headset or whatever by all means take us
on you're getting a horrible horrible
echo I have been crying to anyone who
will listen to me about it
that if you're assuming we're gonna get
this blue wave you'd you'd better have
be registering people to vote and doing
all of the things because I am not at
all convinced that we're going to have
this blue wave because just because
Alexandria Acacio Cortez won her primary
and Doug Jones defeated a serial child
sex assault or in a special election in
Alabama and some of these other few
incidents there is nothing guaranteed
about this blue wave everybody who wants
to see the blue wave should best be out
there registering people to vote and
explaining that if you don't we're gonna
have the same thing on November whatever
the data is that we had the day after
the November 2016 election where what
everybody's in a daze how did Trump win
what happened yes who's the president
now and it's going to be another two
years of what we've been seeing so I am
by no means assuming there will be a
blue wave agreed that was my question
thank you man all right appreciate it
thank you John for the call three one
eight I don't know where three one eight
is never have we've never gotten a call
from that before